هنا الطفلان الطفلان في هذه اللحظات كما
نشاهد الدفاع المدني تعمل بكامل
جهدها من اجل انقاذ ما يمكن
لكن على ما يبدو ان
هؤلاء شهداء اطفال كانوا يا شباب يلا قد
خلد الى النوم في هذه الليله وتم قصف
المنزل وتدميره على رؤوسهم يا عري عدد من
الشهداء هناك ايضا عمليه بحث في منطقه
اخرى من هذا المنزل الذي تم تعال اصفه الى
جانب
عمليات يا عم فتش الي تق اوي تقوم بها
طواقم الدفاع المدني هناك اصوات انفجارات
في مواكن قريبه من هذا المكان الذي نتواجد
فيه هنا ايضا عمليات
فحث اطفال ثلاث اطفال الاب واطفاله وثلاثه
صغار اكبرهم ثلاث سنين اثنين تووا طفل
فكره هو ومراته وابوه واخوته كلهم استش ه
زي ما انت شايف اطفال نايمين ناس مدنيين
مدنيين هم في العسكر ولاهم
مدنيين يا عم بس يا عم
خلص لاطلع انت
عند
يا
[موسيقى]
الله هيك هذا خلص هذا عاي اللي هنا طلعناه
الثاني الحجر هذا لوعه بخلص ايدها
ارفع اللي فوق عشان رجلها تحت عندك انت
واقف يلا يا شباب
يلا هات حماله ثانيه
حماله
ياعم
طلعت
هلع
يا